bonsoir jo bithume qui troue et enfin
que la couleur est annoncée
c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
beaucoup d'entre vous chez la plus
mauvaise nouvelle après midi parce que
j'ai des gens aux montants nous ont
bassiné la tête par semaine toute la
semaine avec les informations dont vous
feront vous avertit que l'émail blessure
à la cheville je vous a dit que hauteur
alors problèmes d'héritage départements
en vigilance orange et g
arrivé ici la dcri fait qu'au mexique 10
ans ou moins
la paix c'est cool comme ça je vais
pouvoir découvrir apprendre c'est
l'imagination pouvoir et là patatras
encore chance
et en même temps je suis en voulant pas
ce que je vais aller cette réputation et
nous méritons focalisation je suis pas
beaucoup pousser dans la vie quotidienne
dressé à creuser les sujets de fond va
proposer ce qui est faux a créé au jour
les moments je vais par exemple tchané
je leur dis mais ça me ferait qu'on
fasse un sujet sur l'afrique post qui
comment l'innovation des rituels cette
inspiration pour dix nominations ses
franchisés ces patients ccc le monde qui
vient en aide d'un million des six s'est
passé denner mêmes qu'à six à avoir
attendu des mains créatives en
biomédecine sais c'est pas assez concret
ça concerne c'est celle où on peut
toujours mais ça leur est question dans
les chaînes mais en revanche les
départements en vigilance orange
alors j'ai l'impression que j'ai assez
bien coûter en fait je manque de la
prise de recul moi même et quand est-ce
que je peux t'on nous pourrons avoir
pris du recul similaire dans le
journaliste je suis censé faire passer
ces informations je n'ai pas su recul
comment elles se font aider à comprendre
le montant journée mais si en même temps
je ne comprends pas ce monde moi même
investi final je m'en tiens allez qu'une
des événements sans en comprendre le
sens profond citer un exemple pour
illustrer cela en chine
oui nous sommes durant les printemps
arabes son plein dedans mais il ya
quelques années c'était encore plus
l'actualité d argent quitter la halle à
la méditation et les guerres pour se
réfugier ailleurs que dans ces pays
touchés par ces comptes en arabe est
elle selon la presse
chacune un chiffre précis au bn ils nous
donnent leur appui millions d'immigrants
clandestins qui se trouveraient donc sur
une seul revers et à ce moment là où
jadis un documentaire choc est la plus
sur un sujet qui est proche des
questions migratoires est jolie mais
d'où vient ce chien ruine alors je pense
et puis je je découvre qu'en fait c'est
une agence romaine stahl frontex
c'est l'agencé avec l'ajout de protéger
les frontières qui va exprimer ce
chiffre là puis viendra la porte 2014
j'avais l'intègre élite bien ce film ils
feront des sceaux dit je sais pas
ensuite c'est la commission européenne
qui
la commission européenne qui savait si
moi voir ci-dessous chiffres un peu plus
tous les ebooks ce chiffre
réponse oui la police d'être
alors je pose encore je découvre que ce
chiffre a été publié pour la première
fois dans un rapport édité par un sombre
origine suisse romande
je contacte son moteur gmail vient ce
chiffre est 10 e
le figaro a dit guillaume ne retrouve
pas qu'ils nous réciter capillon leur
destin dans l'europe et neuf donc les
pays de l'europe de l'ouest et son union
j'ai fait un saut de la mounine vous
avez un chiffre un peu au pif et du oui
je suis vraiment désolé ce n'était pas
du bon travail de ma part je m'excuse tu
mets souvent des il ya 500 personnes qui
sont terrorisés par ce chiffre qui
traînent dans les médias que tous les
médias aussi qu'entre 2 8 millions
d'imagés est un bon 10 m en et c'est
relativement l'exemple d'une information
circulaire qui circulait la circulaire
qui finit par sombrer à forte valeur a
été récitée par tous mais qui auraient
été ne correspond en rien à la réalité
qui m'aime ou chamonix une distance de
l'art est il moins de chiffres aussi
très intéressant
chaque année en france ce serait sans
nul n'ignore qu'il s installe en france
et ça c'est un chiffon vous plains
professions de santé de 100 lits les
films et populiste coupable puisque 200
milles en fait on se représente 210 gros
c'est l'équivalent de jeu de rennes
imaginez mon règne qui reculé tous les
ans en france
alors si vous voulez c'est rennes je
vais par m mon général nous on aimerait
que ça
il ya ensuite un génial on est pions
tour il est fou et puis après c'est les
banlieues qui s'étend consacré pour
leurs tentacules
il met rennes qui arrive tous les ans en
france les affolant
alors je m'intéresse à nouveau ce
chiffre et je comprends en fait que
celui de son nez le vide enfin millions
qui viennent le kijun sen en france tous
les ans d'abord il ya soixante mille
étudiants mais c'est sûr il faut quand
il faut et puis parmi bien d'autres mais
aussi les éléments naturels personnes
qui sont pas franchement française qui
vit en france depuis des années si le
travail est lié mais qui peuvent décider
de france est l'arrêt ce qu'il faut
regarder c'est pas tant les deux sens
mais le seul fait la différence et qui
alors entre et ceux qui sortent et le
sol c'est 80 mg et 90 me dont une grande
majorité
j'admire depuis l'europe de curable et
28 donc en fait 90 saison et 238 pensant
la population française à 0 128 ce qui
fait que la france est aujourd'hui
classé au 16e rang sur 28 ans ratio
entre populations migrantes et les
populations
donc quand on regarde beaucoup les
chiffres ça je trouve ça beaucoup moins
inquiétant
je fais quand un documentaire est
diffusé lundi soir
occupé à l'emprunt que je tiens à lancer
dans ce chiffre c'est que je suis moi en
tout consommer tant fonction
complètement sur vous et souvent je suis
sur un volume d'informations avec nous
et ils voient qu'ils sont fausses
wallace et je suis sous informés de les
socios informations essentielles et
christiane mois l'apparition la
fondation ce qui paraît essentiel et
après quelques années chez terra
constater les choses à regarder à écrire
fine et l'univers c'est que le monde 25
direction qui radicalement opposée à ce
que je voulais créer sentir moi lorsque
je lisais un fort match et des années je
trouve en afrique et jeux pour décrire
plus précisément à abidjan la côte
d'ivoire
et puisque je vous parle d'immigration
vers l'est c'est sur ce terrain là je
fais un reportage avec lézignan ceux qui
rêvent d'un miracle qui voudraient
partir de côte d'ivoire pour aller voir
donc nécessaire j'ai un premier
premières habituellement rapport est
tellement fort qui est que quand je
rencontre ces hommes tous les hommes que
les femmes des hommes à d'abord on en
parle des aventures et ses coûts et bien
en avoir un mais ça fait rêver
il s'appelle aventure et donc nous
devons réfléchir objectivement nos
francs si je constate mais en revanche
havas il se plaint juillet et être
aventuré en fait servir un échec
l'aventurier dans la femip cei qui a été
choisi pour partie réussir au plus haut
gagner là bas est ensuite renvoyé
l'argent en voyageant par wissam il est
par exemple et nous déjà il ya une
notion chère et qui se pose là dont les
thèmes qui sont formées par ces gens là
pour son argent vous parler avec eux et
avoir compris ce qu'ils aient
l'aventurier qui m'a traversé l an plus
tard à feu et peut-être traverser la
france à pied cet attentat d'être
peut-être d'ailleurs vu dans la main est
sensible surtout après ce qu'il a fait
moi je suis j'ai le concile à ordure ils
sont cuits salle à manger là je suis
toujours en kata mais maxime à matisse
et 1 restant abidjan les gens c'est
l'ondé restreint des gens que dix voix
sur mon tabouret avoir mal bouffe qui
l'ont pas vers la france c'est pas ça
qui les intéressent
ce qui les intéresse ce n'est son action
est en fait le meilleur c'est pas la
france l'espagne la suède la veille
non c'est l'agenais quand ariane legault
le mozambique et l'afrique du sud et à
ses obsessions je découvre un chiffre
qui ne me laisse pas continue de nos
super fier c'est qu'on fait semblant
avec un kids in ear en europe et 95 kg à
7 95% des migrants africains arc dans un
autre pays avec 2 % - là puis 3% moment
reste donc moi j'aime à la conception au
ps en fait je pensais que j'étais en
veille devant en fumée
fraîchement parler parce qu'en général
devant qui relaie les emplois en raid et
je constate ce jour rien à carrer et
équitable pas de bon sens puisque par
exemple très intéressant que j'aime ça
sur votre sujet toujours la migration
dans un autre pays et je trouve à ce
moment là au mexique
et puis que ses enfants dans une ville
il s'appelle nogales c'est ce qui se
trouve en fait le rsa affrontiez entre
mexique les états unis
c'est une vie par israël frontière se
trouve le mur ce n'est le jeu le
président de l'aja d'ouvrir en france et
à l'occasion de ce reportage
je mets la main sur un chiffre encore
plus super g en réalité le solde
migratoire entre mexique les états unis
est favorable mais si vraiment il ya
plus de même des américains qui vont
venir chaque année au mexique
vu le mexique chez le psy op comment le
mur fesci qui devait donc ça samedi j'en
fais n'a complètement bossant mrc de
sherbrooke perception rend compte que ce
que je pensais
jean salon d'ester la première fois et
pas du tout vrai que tout ça un grand
mais les migrations
qui aurait parié correspondait un
certain nombre de l'outil près d'elle
j'étais fait pour le canton
consommateurs du médicament sont
complètement sur le terrain s'avère
complètement inversé je dis ça parce que
en réalité s'ils ont bien constaté ça
c'est pas celui là
ici c'est qu'en fait si on va vers le
mexique après le choix ou pour aller
plutôt l'afrique du sud que la france
c'est parce que le dynamisme économique
de ces pays là que l'autre c'est parce
que en réalité il ya un meilleur intérêt
qu à une épée du sud pour ces gens là
qu'une des pays du nord récemment a rien
changé dans un pays c'est payant de
l'iss est là c'est la première
croissance mondiale ces points les
meilleures performances
c'est d'ailleurs la performance des
fraudes sur les 27 avaient rêvé ce prix
c'est la quatrième des meilleures
performances mondiales simple et une
progression de son pays 2 506 4 ans ans
dans quatre ans je pense que partout sur
terre arrive sur dans un set et j'avais
leyens abeba en algérie et je me relâche
je ne compte pas ce que j'allais bien
suspect toute manière là pour moi
l'ethiopie ne sais pas si vous vous
rappelez plus jamais les joues vie dans
les années 40 ans et l'ont fait sur
terre c'était deuxième pays le plus
pauvre de la planète
tout y est les guerres
monde et dont les causes et des
collectes de riz pour les envoyer dans
des camions qui aurait bravé les parts
de route faut arriver justice en france
avec le en vérité pas à ce rythme là
mais je finis c'est un pays qui règne
dans les pays à revenu intermédiaire
d'ici 2025 et l'ethiopie participe de ce
domaine plus large de cette ribambelle
de paix du sud d'état on appelle du sud
qui en réalité sont en train de
rattraper le retard pour finalement avec
ma façon de penser mais aussi de
l'éducation européenne nous centrer je
suis habituée ces schémas finalement
assez binaire pour me représenter move
et quelquefois d'ailleurs qui représente
des rapports de domination le nord
contre le sud les pays et je voulais
payer pour les pays développés et en
développement et non réalité je ne peux
que constater le phénomène sont infimes
en pub
est-ce que ça qui quelquefois même il
n'ya qu'une norme il suit j'en viens
avec moi même une une à poser quand même
une sorte de de réflexion mais qui est
aussi au fait une une petite
méthodologie que je m'applique pour
essayer de penser ce monde tel que je
t'ai vu ils n'ont pas plus apprécié
j'avais pressenti à bout pour essayer de
me rapprocher de cette réalité qui est
pas forcément facile m'emballe pas si je
pouvais jouer deux mois ça c'était
direction
d'abord lorsque je regarde
lorsqu'une un consensus se cristallise
et notamment dans la profession déjà je
n'achète pas ça bouffe en sus des
primaires je m'en méfie un consensus est
une posture confortable pour masquer les
femen beaucoup plus simple ensuite tous
ces domaines ne veut plus être analysés
de façon purement le cas passé par
conclure mondialisé de pensée va de même
de l'aspect local
et puis troisièmement et sa non
seulement convaincu c'est que le terrain
ne manque pas de fresques chaunu était
avec une deux avec une des choses
radicalement différent de ce que j'avais
plus de france et même de partis il ya
toujours un voyage plein de gens du
terrain et des cinémas des idées
fraîches dessinée qu'il vaut la peine
s'il faut bien comprendre c'est plus une
fois que je me suis dit ça pour la tête
en fait ma conception du nord ont
basculé dans ma tête
bien qu'une n'y a plus de sud et s'il
existe ce nom et ce sud
mais en fait peut-être qu'en fait ces
pays n'auraient pu agir envers ces jeux
puisque au delà d'exploration au-delà
des murs fait c'est de montrer ce que
c'est si des questions c'est son point
de location de sa bascule s'est
cependant se font des idées le monde qui
s'est déplacé basque par exemple le
centre du monde bascule par le pacifique
en 2010 par des bios ont déjà coupé le
signal est passé sous la barre des 50%
la chine s'était moqué frère est le
premier producteur de brevets c'est le
pays qui est dans les chiffres le plus
dignement
fenêtre avait chanté produire du riz
c'est aussi des produits qui produit le
plus d'articles scientifiques
record battu chose pour 2016 les
influents de l isolement et plus mon
église chrétienne du monde se trouverait
sur moi serons peut-être en italie et en
europe
non elle se trouve en corée du sud si
lisse du plus petit du niveau d'eau
assainie l'apurement industrie
cinématographique du monde se trouve non
pas hollywood où elle se trouve en moins
c'est beau ou le plus grand moule du
grand centre commercial nostromo d'être
aux états unis pas du tout c'est le
dubai moules dont les élire dans les
émirats arabes et lance ici pour moi en
2010 9 mai prochain la france sans du g7
elle partie des sept éléments les plus
grands de la planète
en juin le g20 existe encore pour se
consoler en disant qu'on a encore des
choses à faire
faire du monde mais son ton g7 il faut
deux chirurgiens jeunesse avait rapporté
l'entrée sont réelles en chine une
région n'oubliez pas quand même que
l'homme blanc 260 et aujourd'hui la
chine a été la première puissance de la
planète pour presque sont donc
finalement vont en chine
l'incident la domination géante après
que je me la représente en réalité j'ai
parenthèse l'histoire et cette
parenthèse et surtout ainsi femmes le
monde aujourd'hui sur groix après avoir
constaté cela c'est tout le monde qui
est des occidentales is et s'endormit
sud ou quand le nom mais j'existe
agissent à fond entre c'est ce monde là
est incroyable le monde dirait qu'il est
formé par la chine
elles seront extrêmement bien il ya dix
ans une éternité à mon sens économique
du terme c'est à dire que les petits
soubresauts et comme ils sont en mission
de la chine ne sont rien par rapport à
ce qu'ils aillent cesl et il va fondre
sous ce nom là ceux ci ont extrêmement
ème salon de porter des fabuleuses
opportunités pour qui c'est justement
prendre toutes ces perceptions à
hambourg et faire le chemin à l'envers
différents intellectuelle classique fait
ce choix
ça permet précisément d'éviter le move
et décide de vous les décisions de faire
des mauvais choix stratégique man 2 et
sushi ça permet d'éviter des
désillusions c'est mérité de prendre
tout un tas de mauvaises décisions faire
ce choix
ça permet des pénalités en fait le
risque de ne pas avoir vu précisément
ces hommes ces femmes
ces multinationales qui font leur chemin
à l'envers qui traça si un robot et qui
font une révolution au sens littéral et
elle fait la leçon nous est expliqué
fleur au sens d'un cheminement à
remerciements ces prochaines années
j'espère continuer à voyager j'espère
continuer à dépasser nos filiales
regarde le centre de façon différente
soul et dézoomer début ce qui est
peut-être ces révolutions allez
continuellement la honte de ces
aventuriers as cru aussi tracent leur
route
amour et sur cette route qui ne vous
arrange